Hello Youtube artificial intelligence
bots.
Please don't demonetize me.
This video has nothing to do with brexit
and there's absolutely nothing offensive
about the word cockney.
Today I want to examine a unique and
extremely creative form of English slang
called cockney rhyming slang.
Cockneys are traditionally defined as
people living within earshot of the bow
bells of the Saint Marie Leveaux church
in the east end of London,
but the term cockney has come to refer
to working class Londoners in various
parts of the city and surrounding areas.
Cockney rhyming slang was first
mentioned in a book published in 1859
and had probably begun to be used in the
1840s so what the heck is it?
Okay,
I'll give you the most basic and cliche
example of cockney rhyming slang.
I went up the Alpha one Perez,
the phrase apples and pears is a
substitute for the word stairs.
So you take a word that rhymes with the
original word and then use it to create
a pair of related words.
That pair of words now represents the
original word in this case stairs.
Here's the most interesting part.
The second word of the pear,
the one that rhymes with the original
word is usually left out as in,
I went up the apples,
but how are you supposed to know what it
means?
Well,
originally this kind of slang was not
meant to be understood by everybody.
It was created by street merchants and
criminals in order to prevent other
people from understanding what they were
talking about,
but it soon became a colorful form of
expression rather than just covert
communication.
Let's look at some more classic
examples.
We'll start with the word house.
A rhyming word is mouse a complimentary
where it is cat.
So cat and mouse means house.
I went inside the canton mass and the
apple and pears,
theoretically possible to shorten both
of the rhymes and say the sentence,
I went inside the car and up the air
force.
But it would probably be said the long
wait in order to be less confusing.
Here's another example using an animal
word.
The original word is phone.
Phone rhymes with bone.
What animals are normally associated
with bones.
Dogs of course.
So dog and bone means a phone.
So there's this sentence,
pause this.
The dog meaning passed me the phone in
cockney speech,
sometimes the plural pronoun us can be
used with the singular meaning instead
of me.
Here's one more sort of household object
freezer.
A rhyming pair is Mona Lisa.
Notice here that in my North American
accent,
Lisa and freezer don't run,
but the cockney dialect and most
dialects of England or non Roddick,
meaning that the are consonants are only
pronounced before.